it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes now what in the world you guys
movie fights movie fights movie movie
fights live gotta say what up towel
nation who cast a gala nation throw your
O's up that's a new thing
okay so we got a groovy Orlando Magic
that's what happens when you see cooler
[Laughter]
oh my god GT man I love you my friend
uh we got a fun show and we got three
fun dudes to fight it out today first um
you know them you'll love them from all
over screen junkies Collider etc and
published author Ken NAB's on please
breakdown tell me what exactly that is
in your hotline I am I'm like a snake
oil salesman going out of town to town
selling my wares Austin so why we love
Star Wars my new book from manga
publishing or through mango publishing
available now bookstores amazon barnes &
noble indeed man all those things it is
a it's a hundred essays on why why we
love Star Wars how that sounds freaking
amazing like it kind of a must-have for
any Star Wars fan and I thought well
that's a good idea how I like what
you're saying sounds good makes the
perfect stocking stuffer from Memorial
Day can excite have you here and
congrats on the book making a friend
that's awesome our second fighter you
know from hyper RPG and the L rain
network
party Mr Cameron right good times um how
long have you been with El Rey now it's
exciting stuff I've been there we'd have
been the shows has been going about
three or four weeks now the new episode
airs tonight if you're watching this
live on El Rey at 10:30 it's me Hector
Navarro Kelley new Jude and Vanessa
griten so many people you are familiar
with we talk about geeky topics and
sometimes we cook food which is what
happens tonight we make hamburgers oh
good times
well that's awesome dude and please give
my fond regards to Robert Rodriguez tell
him I enjoy to lead a battle angel oh
he's just everybody's favorite young man
he you can often find him in the dojo
and across the hall thank you for coming
across do some movie fighting Joestar
happy to be back I am it could go either
way how I am here subbing in for Marquis
and McCarty who books something cool
today so send her some congrats and love
on Twitter but I did choose my own
answers it could go either way but I am
I'm so proud of these two dudes for
everything cool that's been happening oh
hell yeah I'm stoked to be at the table
with a thank you yeah because a lot of
times you'll have to fill in for someone
and do their answers and it's like okay
for Spielberg's best movie the terminal
and here's why and I win this show so I
don't know crap shoots Rennick could
have been always you could have gotten
old
well thanks for being here brother and
deciding all these shenanigans and high
jinks it's going to be myself and the
damn cam oh and that's I know what's
going on over there great energy
damn good to see you brother hold it
down in the fact zone yes doing my best
hoping not to get any worlds you
tomorrow you worlds mixed up six one six
is versus nineteen nine nine nine nine
because favorite spider yes and that's
the beauty of what we're doing here we
got fans that love it and watch it so
thank you sir and our social media
ambassador Miz Daniel Radford
not fighting today today I am back to
being the voice of the people so the way
that this works is in case of a tie or
in case we just need an answer to be
given we will have a poll there are lots
of really fun polls that are happening
on Twitter the only poll that counts for
this purpose is the one on YouTube if
you have any questions about how that
works ask someone in the chat should be
done in the description down below but
join us on the hashtag movie fights live
on Twitter because I'm always in there
trolling for good answers if I see
something I like I might shout you out
during the show Danielle I saw someone
tweeted that your movie fighting prowess
deserves a title shot did you want to
drop any hot takes here I did Danielle
do you want to call anyone out you want
to uh anything at all Dane war danby
danby damn damn you're a very talented
man well thank you as are you a very
talented person okay she's gonna
assess against each other how not trying
to set you against each other but Danny
Danielle I mean she's been proving
herself up here at the at this table and
so that's all I'm saying like it Dan you
are beyond formidable but Danielle she's
she's showing out like a competition
free zone on the couch now where does my
net be enemies over here no we have to
work together as I said to someone on
Twitter that's not a question I need an
answer to just gonna be fire over there
Danielle a lot of damn related stuff
happening right right there in that
general area all right so again how this
works the first player to four points
wins after the first three rounds we go
to the speed round where the top two
competitors will face off and someone
can be down three oh and the other
person can make a furious comeback you
guys you came to a movie fight why do
you say we get it started JT drop that
sick ass package
[Music]
well thanks dork so question one I
haven't seen ya I'm very excited John
wick three Parabellum opens in theaters
this weekend so we asked what movie
character from any film or series of
films would definitely be able to kill
John wick what movie character would
definitely be able to kill John wick and
we go with Ken nap sock
first up resolved the character that
would most likely match up and kill him
kid what if I did that the whole time
that'd be horrible hi John wick he is a
man he said got a broken heart he's lost
a dog he's got a particular set of
skills but better than that other guy
he's got weapons he's got he's got
fighting chops I want someone who's kind
of an equals gonna put up good fight but
in the end is gonna murder him and that
is why I'm going with natasha romanoff
aka Black Widow from them they're Marvel
Pictures all right this is I won't cook
to Ornish you now but this is this is a
this is a great fight this is Marshall
looks like Joe you're a ninja now I look
at your Instagram feed
you know I'm looking at two fighters at
the top of their game that's what I'm
going with Black Widow alright thank you
ken going with Black Widow Cameron I
decided to go with a formidable foe I
messed up that word time out there I
love formal folks former foes I would
side to go with a real BA in the movie
industry someone who knows how to not
just kick ass but drop some sick jams
I'm talking about venom there he is
and we again to the Y in the arguments
all right Thank You Cameron going with
venom right there with his gene Simmons
like tongue Joe how I very much
appreciate the the choices that both of
my opponents made but I feel like when
when it comes down to someone who could
not only go toe-to-toe with John wick
but also ultimately defeat him take his
life there's a really only one answer
and that's Tumtum from the three ninjas
franchise mmm-hmm Tom Tom of course
being the smallest of those ninjas
kid in the yellow yes thank you the kid
in the yellow gate that's Tom Tom Tom
Tom of course along with his two
brothers was trained as a ninja every
summer by their grandfather played by
the legendary Victor Wong and I believe
that tum tum has both the skill set and
the mindset to kill John wick largely
because he's a talented fighter he's
resourceful and he's a small child and
John wick would probably not kill a
small child all right Joe going with Tom
Tom Joe what close you're gay it's just
traditional white all right fight it out
fellas he does I don't go to Joe I gotta
say right now Black Widow great option
problem is Black Widow too much of a
hero this is movie fights not comic
fights in the comic books she does take
out humans left and right in the movies
though she's pretty much killing aliens
as far as other human beings go she's
usually keeping people alive keeper to
much read on her she's not gonna wanna
take another life if you had gone rock
if you had gotten rocky or Cole I'm not
have said you might have had this no I
do Sonny the boulevard too distracted by
Emily and the other ones too much of a
hothead to pull off the fight they have
something to fight for and also they had
no problem poisoning those villains from
the first film those Wayne's World
knockoffs they had no problem
Tom Tom for lack of a better term is the
multiplicity clone version of a
Michelangelo you picked a he touched my
Pepe Steve to kill everybody venom has
no problem killing people and also super
bulletproof super pretty much anything
proof venom is gonna be eaten heads I'm
not saying it's not gonna be a good
fight but you're gonna be one venom to
do this because at the end of the day
you picked a hero
you picked a hero I picked an antihero
and it's how heroes kill look well John
wick is gonna be mo more motivated to
kill your guy and I think I think that's
how the fights gonna end with him
settling some kind of score lets me I
know what you're playing on Joestar I
know what your little tricks are you're
saying hey John wicks got a heart he
loves dogs let's do it all I have to do
is whisper in John's here this little
bastard kid killed your dog dead God
John wick has no heart when it comes to
just that John wick is easily
manipulated by a simple lie which I
don't think he is as far as venom is
concerned I mean really venom is a loud
stereo away from defeat at any given
point and John wick is a master of gun
foo he's
also gonna be a master of decibel feu in
this fight like he's gonna knock him out
of this fight really Quinn said of
course at your dojo joke you can't
absolutely it was very important so
which job like are we talking about
though is it far to where his house has
been blowing up he is lacking things he
has to go to his assassin friends at
part 3 he has nothing he's on the run so
unless that dog is barking at a certain
decimal point then I'm good to go guys
uh-huh
okay he's lost everything you can still
find things that makes every look almost
every homeless person in Los Angeles has
the loudest stereo in their hands that
I've ever heard in my life I ride the
train in the bus with them every day
that's not an issue about fighting John
wit Cal yeah in Star Trek 4 on the
subway yeah most people fight John wick
head on they make that mistake
whereas tum tum is trained in gorilla
warfare trickery hit and run he's not
gonna make that mistake that the usual
team of 20 stuntmen make by just
charging at this guy's with swords he's
gonna get you then he's gone he's gonna
get you then he's gone like this kid
doesn't like he doesn't need to hold his
own in a one-on-one fight with John wick
because that's not his style that's not
how he's gonna move he's gonna duck he's
gonna leave he's gonna get out of there
I would go with that if not for the
three ninja films where the three ninjas
never took out the main villain grandpa
did both times that's big grandpa
talking about track records venom Lee
says that record day and then it will
tum tum but what will tum tum do in that
moment what what kind of fear will he
experience Black Widow she doesn't have
superpowers she's super skills but she's
still down to fight Thanos and the
aliens that you're bringing up Cameron
she has no fear she will be there
against John wick no matter what he
throws I would go with that however
Black Widow as we saw spoilers for
endgame if you have something to fight
for
you've sin to live for she might
sacrifice herself once John which like
is for my wife and my puppy she might
kill
with Natasha because I feel like we're
not hitting her as easily in as hard as
John wick would sure really she has one
go to the head scissor and well John
John wick doesn't know those he is
getting some kind of dossier before this
all it takes all it doesn't need to know
all these I've seen John wick counter
head scissor maneuvers he's gonna see it
coming a fighter of that prowess is
gonna be able to see someone coming at
him Telegraph that maneuver ah look I
also think she's a dead shot I think
she's not going hot guy of course but I
think she's got enough skill so she
might not even get to physical combat
she might take him out again she's fired
handguns and aliens she's got no fear
and TomTom man like yeah I don't know
why you even doing this to the sweet kid
you know your son
this is your like this is one of the
least horrible things that's happened to
Tom Tom he grew up watching his dad
being kidnapped by a weapons dealer he
got High Noon dat mega mountain he's
knuckled up he's kicked back fighting
Johnny war foot he'll come and work with
all Kogan like that's some [ __ ] to be
honest I'm not sure Tom Tom didn't grow
up to be John wick you might be having
some kind of weird psycho psychoanalysis
a type of battle going on here we might
we might be and who better to take you
out as an old man than you and then a
younger you at your prime and if we're
making the argument that Tumtum is a
weird time loop with John wick I'm all
for it that's fair old me takes me out
of dinner every night but I'll tell you
what heartburn
kids look into it uh again with venom
there I mean it's a solid pick I
understand it but III don't know I just
I just I think John wicks gonna take him
out with the with the the sound
no where's Venom's more stuck on his own
ego I think that he thinks he's a star
now it's we're saying venom is not Eddie
Brock you could kill any Brock and venom
moves from person to person Michelle
Williams you got Eddie with boobs or
venom with boobs moves to this person
who's that for yeah it's a mover and
shaker I feel like that just
with someone who's as efficient at
killing as John wake that all that
people jumping is so it's just so much
wasted oh yeah yeah yeah don't we go get
real tired yeah oh man you have you have
to come come at him with someone who's
equally as efficient and in the first 20
minutes of the first three ninja movies
tum tum is taught by his grandpa played
by the legendary Victor Wong for six
points on the human body where someone
can be struck once and be immediately
taken out of a fight and disabled IDs
shot that gears and move to our final
thoughts Ken please give us your final
thoughts on black widow verse John wick
huh honey facts do you know about Tom
Tom this is really your whole life's
work coming down to this moment
pretty much wow that's impressive look
here's the thing with black widow I
think we know she's one of the secret
weapons of the Avenger she's with a glue
that makes it stick she holds him
together particularly at the end and I
think if she's properly motivated and
John wick going around killing
indiscriminately because he lost a pet
he's gonna motivate her and it's gonna
give her something to fight for she's
gonna she saved the world she's now
gonna end this fight Black Widow is your
choice to kill John wick thank you Ken
Cameron problem is you guys pick people
who have things to lose that's the worst
thing you can ever do if you're facing
against John wick Black Widow she's part
of a family's part of a troop not just
the Avengers the human race and with Tom
Tom he's the youngest brother
he needs me and I agree grandpa did
teach them five points but as seen in
the movie Tom's um not quite good at it
as rocky and Colt however venom has a
lone being he's the last one of the
symbiotes except for possibly carnage
which we did not see was not in the film
yet he's the last of the symbiote he's
got nothing to lose her and I guess is
he if he if he gets a van he gets killed
he can jump to another person jump to
another person John wakes only a man
he's got to get exhausted and he's gonna
be fighting someone who's got nothing to
lose
all right thank you Cameron Joe how the
issue with Black Widow is you know not
only the the one headscissor trick here
but she's also a support player
she's a support player for the Avengers
at most instances where we've seen black
widow strike out on her own or even in a
duo she's either had a lot of issues
holding her own in a fight or she's
under look dead
the issue with venom again even beyond
you
this will not even be on the decibel
issue is the issue like Kiana's not even
going to have to use John wick skills he
can throw back and go full Bill and Ted
wild stallions this guy to death like it
it figures there's just not a solid
fight to be had there again TomTom
trained every summer by his legendary
grandfather played by Victor Wong he's
very chaotic and unpredictable I don't
think John wick can properly prepare for
him he can multitask one time in three
ninjas he did a full psychotic while
eating red vines I think that's very
impressive and speaks to his abilities
and again you know you're sort of
talking about some time depending on his
three brothers or not being as good at
them but in the third act of the first
three ninjas movie in the cargo-ship
sequence they're all separated and tum
tum more than holds his own BAM there it
is round one in the books
damn anything in the fact zone I was
diggin Ken's resolved the bait format
which is probably why he abandoned it so
quickly because I like to paint not too
many of us left
get all speech debate team Dan over
there yeah it's true third place in the
central high school tournament
your forensic Irishman to do that my
best friend Michael wait
okay sorry Venom's weaknesses not
somebody someone so much decibels it's
about hurts
four to six thousand Hertz is about what
his when his weaknesses as as
established in the last film in 2018 so
venom which I assume is what you know
amongst the ones that we're discussing
so it's not so much it's not just the
allowed nough sub the sound that is also
the the Hertz range which is a separate
as well that's all I got
great thank you Dan yeah three wildly
different characters so hmm to Wong foo
on paper the the arguments say one thing
but just now in actuality when put on
their feet hmm we have I think we have
some dings against Black Widow just like
a limited are
and old and her motivation to kill
another human was called out that's how
you know black widow foot week and we
are talking bout Black Widow from the
MCU and yeah it came down to venom and
Tumtum for me yeah
not the first time you had to say that
the 90s were crazy venom in my Tumtum
and yeah it was a real back-and-forth
battle but at the end of the day I
thought there were more dings against
against Joe's choice here he never took
out the main villain he and he and he is
a child that is at his younger self like
at his maximum and Alan thing is quite
there too but I said John wick would
hesitate in killing a child and that's
when the child strikes and no one no one
challenged that hmm all right I go Joe
allowed to address the judge after the
fact you know there's a lot at stake
here it's not a title vote but the
winner gets these two cupcakes at the
bar this joker like thing here we got
room for two more
I fight with the knife
joe-joe slipped it in and he just thank
you can't be my lord and future this was
a difficult decision tonight and I have
to say as a judge I I cannot in all good
conscience give weight to information
given post arguments I can't post
argument other ones that wouldn't
brought it up in get talk yourself out
of a point Joe I thought that Alice
first looked like witnessing goes I
thought that the determination of Black
Widow as we know her from the films yes
there are too many mitigating factors
that couldn't necessarily be avoided she
does have great prowess but she is a
person of conscience as well I thought
that was a good point again so it was
between venom and Tom Thomas so often is
in my head and I'm debating anything and
I disregarding the the extraneous
information given after the fact I have
to say the person that argued for their
choice most confidently and most
consistently and countering all points
against was Joe so I have to also give
the point to Joe Joe Tom Tom cake says
cannon mouth off Wow Tom would kill John
wick Wow no one chose store the Hulk I
was going for I was booking an even
fight man you know I was booking I was
booking like a wrestling I wasn't
looking a winner
and resolved dan Merle has abandoned me
Daniel
head even Bill
all right so as of right now the polls
said with 42% Venom TomTom with 29% 27%
for black widow very close some other
things that people recommended a lot of
folks wanted neo they wanted that can
someone actually suggested Ted that's
good too that would be a good one I've
Santos Kujo a lot of people with the
idea that it's a dog dog
Mechagodzilla which doesn't seem super
appropriate agent 57 from hitman now if
y'all were talking about hitman the
movie I don't name hitman the game
doesn't count b12 a cigar 57 passenger
if you're betting on black then you're
fine
and then many people saying Laura from
Logan would have been a really good
choice yeah yeah good she's also got the
kid thing and oh yeah yeah I would have
gone for that one alright so Joestar
takes the point and it is Joe with one
ken and Cameron looking to get on the
board
alright here's question number two got a
new trailer for Maleficent - Angelina
Jolie this week what Disney villain
deserves their own live-action spin-off
oh yeah
there's a lot of them to choose from
what Disney villain desert zone
live-action spin-off question two stars
player number two Cameron alright well I
had to think about this and I wanted to
go to the classic Canon because I think
about Maleficent was not just that it
was oh hey look it's the villain that's
the movie it's about changing the story
changing the perspective for giving you
a different perspective diving deeper so
I wanted to go going through the list I
was like you know what I want to see
about the world of the wicked stepmother
from Cinderella well right the wicked
stepmother from Cinderella jump how yes
sir
I wanted a different different route
with with this one
everyone was Sid from from Toy Story I
don't know that this would be the most
fun movie in the world but I do think it
would be at an important one that Disney
should take the opportunity to tell it
makes a billion
zillions with all of it the rest of its
franchises they can they can take a
chance on this I think we we under
served boys in media and how they're
portrayed with bullies you know like
kids our kids are angry they got a lot
of anger issues we don't treat them with
a lot of empathy someone a friend of
mine said once and it's stuck in my head
forever like the difference between like
an S jwk ed and like afar all right kid
is like what chat room that go into
first or like what kid talks to them
first you know and I think that's how
you get a kid like Sid in the toy store
movie so in the film is portrayed as
this like intense like head popping
bully and I think you could you could do
a really cool live-action movie about
this kid like what's his actual life
like what are his struggles like is this
kid actually gonna be able to sort of
pull himself up and become better being
able to mature and change and grow and I
think that would be a cool movie all
right
dissecting the bully Sid from Toy Story
interesting stuff Ken good choices but
both of my competitors here today
happens to be on the dais with you all
I'm going with a classic that's goes
across many different properties and I
know we're talking Disney but there's
definitely some of him strong presence
in the ESOP fables and grim fairy tales
but I know it's Disney I'm going with
the big bad wolf this is a man who is
huffed and his puffed and has blown his
way around many movies and I want to get
his side to Cameron that's an excellent
point
I want to see what happens when you have
pigs squatting on your land and a little
girl trespassing into your neighborhood
causing problems I want to see I like
Joe saying what goes into the making of
a monster alright big bad wolf fight it
out everybody
well my first point about Sid is that as
a Pixar character so I don't know why we
didn't just pick Darth Vader or Magneto
or any of the other studios that Disney
owns but doesn't really seem to do
anything with they seemed Pixar's their
own independent life-changing
answer to the 21st Century Fox logo so
that's my thing against CID also the
movie CID sounds a lot like the Joker
where it's like hey look at the sick
individual what if we watch his movie
and see what he's about and there's lots
of issues possibly with the Joker and
also it's very easily this movie could
just be We Need to Talk About Kevin
which is a fantastic film but it's also
like look at this little weirdo I mean
bring in the business to it I mean I
think Fox Searchlight is done and this
is where this movie but mostly end up so
I don't know if you know what's the
possibility anymore but that's alright
and I mean um be that'd be fascinating
it also sounds like a watching watching
a movie from the point of view of a land
baron which I don't know if that's
worried about the big bet though Three
Little Pigs and drink your milkshake and
that people gonna love it cool my
January Lewis coming out of retirement
for the big pit bull that's a great
casting market down that's in my watch
but I got some good casting as well
because I'm thinking this Disney
Villains especially and I think you can
see this out there is like what I love
about a good classic Disney villain I
don't think we've had one in about 10 15
years is they got they got a little drag
race going for them they got a little
bit of a little bit of the drag queen
thing going you think about your
Ursula's you think about the big
costumes that make up we haven't had
that for a while I think you do evil
stepmother now people are gonna go like
well we just had Cinderella evil
stepmother was just on the screen that's
why the movies not gonna be about
Cinderella it's about the evil
stepmother who is the lady who decides
I'm gonna destroy this young little girl
I'm gonna take this money and my
daughters are gonna reign supreme and
I'm gonna make sure one of them becomes
the princess I want this movie to be
about a bad person and I wanted to be
played by Jessica Lange I want Mommy
Dearest in the world of Disney and you
know what go full phew
give it to Ryan Murphy let the writers
of people versus OJ write this movie
make keep and make it sexy make it fun
make a drag that's interesting I like
this ground a lot um the interesting
thing about your argument to me is you
sort of tried to ding me on this Joker
thing I did but I think both of you are
pitching movies about a fully-grown
villain not obviously not necessarily
like shades of homicidal Joker but I I
think the difference between a movie
like
say it in a movie like Joker is like no
we're not trying to get the humanity of
like this guy that's like a
representation of anarchy and evil like
we are full-on like looking at a child
you know like a kid that needs help is
is from you know a bad home what goes
into that what goes into pulling a kid
out of something like that right so yeah
I don't I don't think it would be like a
look at like does the Joker have any
humanity because I agree that is like a
very dangerous angle to take with a
movie I think yours would take a very
like sort of balanced walk the line of
like karela de Ville this is fun versus
like this is awful and abusive that's it
that's a tough line to walk but if you
could walk it you I think I think you
could pull it off and you know same with
the big bad wolf because you know
ultimately he eats a lady and he's a
murderer I think my think the only thing
with my thing is Sid is like that does
sound like an interesting movie at the
same time I don't think you want to hurt
Toy Story even if this is a live-action
adaptation and since the kid part of the
fun of Toy Story is when woody reveals
himself to Sid and is like so play nice
and Sid throws him in the air runs
around screaming and then we see in Toy
Story 3 is now a garbage man but I think
the thing about it is if you suddenly
show people that like oh Sid is this
very sympathetic character that comes
from a bad home and he deserves
understanding and pity I think you
ruined the third act of Toy Story and
that's a classic you don't want to touch
if you keep Mommy Dearest perspective on
syndrome people go yeah I knew she was
awful and I sees it here I mean I think
it's kind of calling to the attention to
the fact that in Toy Story they kind of
like Biff Tannen to kid that doesn't
necessarily deserve it like he goes from
like washing your car like hi my life is
over because one time a toy scared me
ruins my story but I also don't think it
or stories above criticism with how it
handled that kid oh look Joe you're
doing something really good here I don't
know if you're pitching a great movie or
a pamphlet at a doc and you might be
doing good work for society here the
wicked stepmother I see the picture I
get it when you when you throw on the
Ryan Murphy great ideas as the King John
Martha okay it's great I just you know I
just don't know III love the idea of we
got the big bad wolf is kind of like the
Palpatine of the Disney villain line
area is the Phantom Menace man at all
and I think it's a fascinating story I
want to get it a little bit more into
his rise into power how he gets there
and I'm okay with casting the you know
Danny Lewis great idea thanks Cameron
it's kind of this this not even just a
straight out villains story there and
and and and and exploring more into this
big bad in the universe I think that's
really interesting shades of grey people
like that I could you find a way to make
the big back with wolf sympathetic on
any level III think you couldn't there
also could be a valuable lesson in there
on someone who loses their humanity or
wolf Anna T down to you know doing
things they don't shouldn't be doing
don't murder people you actually don't
eat murder women in your fairy tales I
get it how do we get to that point it's
a little bit of what you pit what you're
pitching to just I think on a more
cinematic scale final thoughts Cameron
hit us with it I think to me there is a
thing where well Disney is a person you
still like really take some daring
chances used to really go for it not on
Bald Mountain is a weird creepy horrific
kind of little short that used to scare
children and I feel like we used to be
able to kind of do that thing in the 70s
days going up to a Baltic long passed
away but the Disney used to kind of go
for it and I think now playing it a
little safe its live-action remakes kind
of point-by-point of them tones I've
already made Marvel Star Wars a love it
all but I want to see Disney take a bit
of a chance drop 40 million make right
let me Ryan Murphy to a movie people
might say well Ryan Murphy after the
first season Bubba that's why it's just
a movie no trilogy nothing like that one
crazy film awesome cast awesome writers
I think would be a fantastic all right
yes it's sealed with a sip of coke zero
all three great pitches again you know
the rise to power of the wolf I don't
know what that rise to power is
necessarily he's in the woods one day
and then he sees my great Johnny Cash
song I think there's a great deal of
really cool sort of schmaltz and
spectacle - - first time I've ever you
smelt on the air - it's a Camryn's pitch
I think you're very hit and miss with
Ryan Murphy he can either give you
something really cool with stuff
substance or he can just force-feed
icing down your throat until you're sick
and you can't taste anything else
anymore haha you know that I feel like
that could go either direction I think
with with the movie like Sid you know
you sort of talked about though we have
to we have to talk about Kevin that's
written a Rams a baby yeah I think you
can in terms of like chances that Walt
Disney used to take I think we also
don't necessarily like respect kids as
much with what we think they're able to
handle in a movie so I don't think that
this would be a movie for adults that's
like about a troubled child I think that
this is a movie for kids about a
troubled kid so that they can see
themselves in and like use as a tool to
sort of be able to work out you know
their own stuff without even realizing
they're doing it when you're in fourth
grade you don't realize you're working
out your stuff you know but like if you
can relate to another kid without really
realizing I think that's cool and you
know that the studio that makes a
billion dollars a year on just like
non-stop punching I think could also do
a really cool responsible thing and make
a really cool movie like this it can
live on Hulu that they now own all right
shout out to fourth graders working out
their stuff always crossing mail couple
things first I do want to refute a point
put out by Cameron that Walt Disney is
dead he's alive and a nice suit beneath
the turkey stand outside Thunder
Mountain
[Applause]
on my reddit thread cranes cryo Janus
joestar's
as fighting the good fight I really
respect what Joestar is trying to do
we're pitching movies in Hollywood we
need four quads and a poster this does
not have it
cancer wolf eating a woman I used to
produce a wonderful show on a paint
network called TV fights and you just
won around for the best FX show not
around and I think that you should pat
yourself on the back not a point here
huh I'll say this what do you want to
see you want to pay your hard-earned
money for dan what do you got in fact
zone and please give us your thoughts on
this round yes
sorry I just typed into my google
buffalo chicken pizza movies here yes
please
maybe at the Alamo I don't doubt that
it's somewhere you are the connoisseur
of where you can get crazy things movie
hot dogs I am it's a I am burping up a
7-eleven sandwich this exact show
version of something at a
non-traditional food place 10 knows
where to find it so the big bad wolf
interestingly one of only two official
Disney Villains that's from a short film
not from a feature-length film it's the
big bad wolf and Pete who's that goofy
capital G goofy looking dog doobies
neighborhood yeah big bad wolf it down
let me ask you a question is the big bad
wolf the the same one that blew down the
pigs houses and ate Red Riding Hood's
grandmother looking this up yeah there
there was most famous for the little red
riding-hood short there was a little red
riding-hood short than the big one wolf
was in but it's not quite the grandmas
there yeah there's a little bit of a
mixing of the classic big bad wolf with
the Disney big bad wolf going on
he's Papa Duke was sorry what was it the
UM the film into the woods was that
Disney cuz big bad wolf was in there
Disney did release into the woods but
it's not animated this is about an
animated character song because animated
big red wolf from the Disney short but
thank you sir for indulging my questions
yes of course
Cameron brought into question whether
Sid why SID because this part of Pixar
would have been counted as a Disney
villain Toy Story was distributed by
Walt Disney Pictures it was produced by
Pixar but distributed by disney it was
technically released as a disney film so
it should count despite the fact also
that it also was acquired by Disney and
Sid is currently owned as a Disney
character so I think I'm both counts
it's fair to call Sid a Disney villain
and yeah those are the two factual say
and then I had another little note but
that's more to do with my decision so no
delay that yeah please let us know how
you are weigh in on this one I think
that well I said I counted out first
just because of the movie pitches it
just it felt like a like a PSA to me not
so much like a movie is more like
something that you would like the
cartoon all-stars that they may just
watch your kids special we had to watch
at health class I'm super in smoke and
also like you know Joe talks like this
tortured soul and became up a garbage
man like I remember said Toy Story 3
maybe he was digging being a garbage man
you know music all day he was like
banging on the truck it's a good city
job maybe
they don't want to do city work the
career shapes looks like someone needs
his own PSA if you were only throwing
garbage into the back of the truck then
maybe somebody says so it's between the
big bad wolf and Cinderella's stepmother
and I and I really do feel listening to
the pitches as a movie goer the ones
that I'm interested in are the ones that
take a classic character and add new
spin to it and I liked a big hot messy
version of Cinderella stepmother whose
name by the way is Lady Tremaine I I
kind of am diggin this pitch for a spill
the tea lady tremaine movie from Ryan
Murphy in the in the spirit of feud
that's one that was most interesting to
me so that's her my vote goes I'm voting
for Cameron alright thank you Dan one
for Cameron there so yeah there was fun
stuff in pitch you had so many gems in
your final argument from buffalo chicken
pizza to your take on Daniel day-lewis
being the big bad wolf thank you like
you really came up it was and it was a
seesaw battle like a three-sided seesaw
which I don't know how that would work
but more on that later
but I really liked your sin thing
because I something that speaks to just
how our development and how we mature
and the paths we choose that I mean
there's something really a substance
there and I thought it was really
thoughtful but at the end of the day I
gotta agree with Dan that you were just
painting something really fun there and
just to let you in the scenery
man that's yeah count me in III go
Cameron Cameron you take the point
Danielle what's going on over there on
the pole did it do wait the pole did a
thing
there we go give me my eye all right so
with 53% of the vote people felt real
bad for Sid
so that was 53% with 26% the big bad
wolf with 20% the wicked stepmother from
Cinderella as far as other answers and
it's not even close overwhelmingly
everyone wants an Ursula movie that'd be
fun that'd be fun huh Liz Oh make it Liz
oh oh yeah I mean does it does Liz he'll
act maybe she does she was actually just
in an episode of new Negroes either her
or have it be what's-his-name from Kimmy
Schmidt oh great he did poor unfortunate
souls for a live in concert and he
sounded amazing yeah he's really
fantastic yeah tiny so you chose Burgess
thank you you're just incredible Kimmy
Schmidt
he is a cannibal tastic supporting
character on that show
excellent oh great so it is a Joe one
Cameron one Ken looking to get on the
board don't forget to buy why we love
Star Wars Star Wars hell yeah I missed
you buddy
question number three what is the best
nostalgia movie from the 80s or 90s that
still hasn't been remade yet I think
that yet might be a little redundant
that still hasn't been remade yes I know
I think it's cynical not redundant maybe
yeah gotcha so the best nostalgia movie
from the 80s or 90s that still hasn't
been remade yet let's start with play
number three
Joe star so I'm not sure if this
question is about pitching the remake or
just which is the best movie that just
hasn't been remade but either way the
answer is surf ninjas it's awesome it's
got everything you need it's got keno
from Turtles - it's got Rob Schneider
this movie is amazing
I
actually watched it today in preparation
I was 11 and it's surprisingly funny
like the script is actually pretty funny
it's it's it's just ridiculous enough
that you're like cool I'm on board and
it's actually pretty smartly written it
sounds like a weird thing to say
it is easily Rob Schneider's best role
it is easily the best performance in his
filmography yeah I don't know it's just
really really fun I feel like we don't
in terms of like things that should I be
remade I feel like we don't get fun
movies that are just aimed for kids
anymore because but Wang's that rrh of
like taking nostalgia and been like no
it's supposed to be for me cuz when I
was a baby fit was for me and it's still
for me how's this going but wings
there's an offshoot of Buffalo Wild
Wings yeah some Cedars just just make
sure they're still rolling on this MOA
falling forward don't buy that but wings
yeah try to go boneless yeah definitely
because the bones are really anyway no
bomb no bones in your butt way I just
think you know in terms of remakes I
don't know I just like leave us out of
it and just make a really fun silly
martial arts surf movie for kids that
kids can get behind and like pretend
they're those those kids you know like
we did with Kino from Ninja Turtles 2
and the three ninjas and all that like
let kids pretend they're the surf ninjas
and make a silly fun thing alright Joe
going with another weird ninja thing not
the first time that's been said this
week thank you Joe
ken what do you got I'm going to a movie
that I know I understand some people say
that there's been rumors that trying to
remake this one it's it's it's number
one a lot of people's lists but it's
from 1984 it's The Last Starfighter
character of Alex Rogan is just a kid
just a kid trying to make it in this
crazy world he's really good at a video
game and a weird character played by the
late great Robert Preston one of his
final roles comes and takes him and and
and the videogame was a recruiting
system which I think we can all agree is
what they are now and it takes him to
the stars to get them involved in a big
space battle very inspired but Star Wars
a lot of things Star Trek of the time
and I think it's its most primed for a
remake because of modern technology
we'll add something to an already
spectacular story all right thank you
Ken Cameron yeah so I just I really had
to think about this one I think going
sci-fi action stuff like that or even
horror we've seen a lot of that and so I
decided and I kind of went with the
argument that's why this would be a good
remake it hasn't been done yet I don't
even think it's in the discussion but I
went with the Alicia Silverstone Amy
Heckerling classic clueless oh yeah yeah
well yeah so I guess I know so for me I
think the thing about it is we often
talk about that comedies don't really
get respected not just an award season
but I think also in the mindset that we
see like invasion of the Body Snatchers
gets made every 10 years or 10 or 15
years and people talk about that where
it's like oh it's great it's able to
talk about the politics of the time this
one was about communism this one was
about this this this and that's like
sci-fi films action films if they do
redo remakes like your point breaks
usually doesn't work but it tries to be
like just out of surfing it's extreme
sorts but I think you might see
variations when people will say oh Mean
Girls is kinda like the clueless but
that was in 2004 we're in 2019 there
really hasn't been a teen movie
especially film for females that can
kind of like speak to them we do have
book-smart coming out but that's sort of
a different vibe that's sort of like two
people who are kind of considering
themselves like we were really books
tomorrow we just the title we didn't
really party we should party clueless on
the other hand share as a character was
really much like I'm friends with
everybody and I think especially in this
time it's kind of cool to kind of have a
main character who's not about the
tribalism that high school can become
that kind of has different groups of
friends I know everyone's gonna say some
stuff about the Paul Rudd storyline but
that's why you'd do a remake you can
kind of smooth over certain things here
and there
it's respecting clueless it's doing a
remake today for teenagers today and I
think it's okay to do that with a comedy
because again if we can do with every
other genre why can't we deal with a
comedy that can speak to teenagers today
fight it out look I'll say this clueless
is a spectacular movie it's a great
choice great soundtrack it's a 90s rock
DJ I can tell you that and a cracker
shake some action let's do it but I
think it's so good that it still holds
up it's like the future I think don't
remain clueless I mean you could throw
in Paul Rudd now it looked the same but
I think I think don't even you don't
even need to touch it surf ninjas wow
that is a silly fun mess I watched that
movie as an adult I lost a bet you want
to know why has to was sunny from the
dubby dubby long story no I was in a
wrestling match were there and I said if
I find interesting match you can let me
watch surf ninjas to my friend and he
booked it I had to watch it so it's a
socially definitely be remaining I'm
talking about when you go down a list of
Wikipedia IMDB you go oh that one that's
a great movie that does not stand up
because the tech doesn't hold up it
doesn't look the same but it's still got
something that would peel appeal to
people and you could spawn it off into a
franchise instead of Robert Preston I
think you cast I don't know let's say
Brad Pitt he's 55 now put him in there
and then give me like a million a young
up-and-coming a actor as as Alex Rogan
and you could you could spin this off
into franchise right now this is we're
talking business and we're talking
something a lot of people do want to see
I do great Joe keep those but lying
adults out of my last starfighter
let's have some fun with this picture
but let's also have something as maybe
is the problem here someday you're gonna
learn that you can't that Brad Pitt
doesn't fit into everything sir someday
so that's right someday it's gonna push
me into this no I really you know I
don't think he does this kid's supposed
to be this bright-eyed bushy-tailed a
video game kid and like you said you
know they are oh no Brad Pitt's the old
guy that comes rescue some
[Music]
Wilford Brimley and cocoon did you know
31 years old age looks different Brad
Pitt 55 still good to go
no you know I think the charm of The
Last Starfighter revolved around how in
awe we felt about arcade games back then
and I don't think you can recapture that
now with the with the way the video
games popular anymore Jo that's true
well no it's not that they're not that
it's that sir it's that it's there
everywhere you know you know it's like
there used to be one arcade machine and
that was it you know maybe you've got
maybe your monthly allowance a Kroger
long enough to go play and like that
that's the aw and the charm of the last
starfighter I agree with everything you
said about clueless it's such really
like that character is so ahead of her
time she's she's kind she's caring she's
not snarky she wants to be friends with
everyone she wants to do right by
everyone I think the problem with Reed
trying to do a remake of clueless is
that the moment you put because you
can't put on you can call the movie Mean
Girls and you're like that kind of feels
like clueless right on you can do
blockers which was recent which is a
great movie you're like some of this
feels like clueless right on but the
moment you call a movie clueless and
you're like we're redoing clueless I
think I think well I think let people
have their pitchforks because guess what
most of the people are gonna complain
about are probably some grody ass dudes
online so let's go play this up games
for the position to not replay clueless
right now Brian Rudy Grantland rice
you're talking about you're talking
about people who can look up online and
star light star fighters number one I
got real good news for them there's a
show called future man on Hulu that says
Brogan made and that he specifically
said was a last starfighter now I know
that's a television show and two little
cameras a little F don't worry the
shooters
here's why what I like about surf ninjas
is that I'll get so ridiculous that it's
almost like a blank canvas like I don't
think anyone is beholden to any
particular moment of surf ninjas they
just remember sort of the dumb joy it
made them feel so you know no one's
gonna be sitting at surfing and just
playing their bingo card like this
better be correct just make an original
pic picture called bodyboard MMA stars
or something you my movie here's a bit
Millie Bobbie Brown as a twitch stream
star someone who's making big money she
thinks she's just doing here in the
liver and playing video games
turns out hi I'm Brad Pitt you need to
get involved in intergalactic war like
wow I'm into this one here's the problem
she just lost all of her twitch
subscribers because she didn't she
wasn't online the next training someone
to be a drone pilot in the
military-industrial complex
sorry camera oh no I hate that for when
it comes around 10 these are my clothes
and thoughts about surf ninjas pal I
think you've got theirs you've got two
really incredible talented actors that
could step into this movie I would cast
Vincent Rodriguez the third who was one
of the main characters and crazy
ex-girlfriend he's incredibly brilliant
so funny plays the like what bro like
California character so so so well an
incredible athlete and then you pair him
with Ian Chen from fresh off the boat he
plays the youngest son the kid is just
like unlimited charisma I think that's
so so fun you could update it and
instead of like a weird like throwback
country that there's suddenly the kings
of maybe you make it like a weird fun
like undiscovered Wakanda type country
and like instead of just being like oh
yeah look now you're a king of like a
weird throwback thing that existed in
the 1400s it's like a cool like modern
civilization instead of Leslie Nielsen
put Ken Watanabe in that with Leslie
Nielsen roll all he's ever done is super
serious dramatic stuff
I'm sorry speaking in hyperbole we best
know Ken Watanabe for just like really
intense
Oscar gravitas stuff or go and let them
fight in Godzilla like let that dude do
deadpan Leslie Nielsen I'm about to
start torturing a guy or interrogating
him and then the phone rings and he has
to be like excuse me and like you know
let him do bits I want to see Ken
Watanabe do bits I think that'd be
hilarious
yeah just a fun silly movie surf ninjas
thanks man Ken
that is a great YouTube read original
Joe that you pitched they're not gonna
I'm talking about clueless again I think
you're pinching a classic and you're and
I don't think it's a bad idea I think
you're getting into dangerous territory
I have got a big giant scope type of big
picture you're gonna go to the theater
to see this
you got a superstar - I put Brad Pitt
Billy Bobby Brown who you want to put I
don't care it's the story it's a genre
that you're selling videogames you could
translate it pretty dropping quarters
now it's about streaming tagline is to
save the galaxy she's gonna have to
leave her couch and I think that's way
less star fighters primed for a remake
thanks Ken Cameron fantastic well I felt
like I heard a lot about the cast in
this one and it's a baller cast but I
didn't really hear too much updates
other than twitch and again I feel like
future future man is out there it does
exist as for surf ninjas taking it away
from being an old country to an
undiscovered country it can be these
people this thing can happen it sounds
like there's too many different moving
puzzle pieces and putting in new puzzle
pieces that it's not really a remake -
surf ninjas it's just gonna be surf
ninjas and name the main hit I'm hearing
good and yes six blockers so that's kind
of ninjas in names how dare you he's
gotta throw the dynamite and not light
it I've seen that movie and I know wow
but with with clueless the main thing
I'm hearing well and I will say yes
blockers is kind of but at the same time
blockers was also about the relationship
with the parents there's a little bit of
includes but Dan had a was definitely
not a major character he was a character
he would not the major character so
blockers isn't quite there and the main
thing I'm hearing again schoolís is like
what people are gonna be mad yeah it's
the internet Game of Thrones people
they're mad they're mad as hell guess
what those two riders are still gonna
make their [ __ ] and I think everyone
else is still gonna make it
let the studio still your own character
you don't care people are mad so guess
what make clueless make it for kids
today make
make a movie for free for girls to be
into something they can look back in 20
years and go that movie was about me and
my life at that time clueless does hold
up but we're also a bunch of 30 year old
saying clueless holds up 23 young man I
was helping you but I think kids today
might watch loose and go that's fun but
there's a lot of things that aren't
there for them will they still go to a
Mighty Mighty Bosstones concert will be
mad regardless thank you cameras all
right let's go to Dan and the facts of
Tino Martinez [ __ ] yep let's start
over
Kino from Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
to is Ernie race jr. thank you
he was and is he was a Sousa he was a
turtle he was both a turtle and a friend
of the turtles he was done Donatello
fighting Donatello in the first one then
he got to be his own character in the
second one and also in the Last Dragon
Danielle was very adamant that I bring
up the his role in the Last Dragon also
in the run down the run his dad plays
action surf ninjas the guy that's
protecting them also featured surfaces
Kelly cool listen he'll soon as you
mentioned and arrested the volley
creator Mitch Hurwitz as surf dude
number two the remake that's where the
character of Tobias came from I have no
idea Ken your streak continues once
again Brad Pitt is 55 years old he will
turn 56 on December 18th so
congratulations I think we know I know
Brett days you know you know Penn I'm
about to blow all of your minds because
he mentioned Wilford Brimley and cocoon
Wilford Brimley in cocoon was 5 years
younger than Brad Pitt is today whoa so
yes you know you're right age ages
people differently because the Brad Pitt
55 and a Wilford Brimley 50 are very
different things
oatmeal it's the right thing to do
together
so yeah three solid pitches Cameron I
feel like they just teamed up and just
like went just like boo and then next
back in forest you're a virgin we can
drive
yeah just hammering you on just how
people would react to clueless and it
just I don't know I feel like that put
you in third place here sorry pal it
came down to a Ken and Joe for me and
Kanna I was really liking where you're
coming from and I thought Cameron
actually helped you when she said she
when he said she'd lose her twitch
followers and I think that could be a
fun aspect to like oh my god what's she
gonna do but the end of the day about
video games being different enough and
yeah I actually wrote down Hulu future
man josh hutcherson right here they kind
of already done that sort of thing so
that gave me some questions
whereas joe was just pitching some good
dumb fun here just a good time and the
more he talked about it the more
interested I got and yes seeing yeah
just a little bit of this nostalgia so
I'm going Joe Dan yeah I'm thinking a
little bit differently I actually tend
to agree with Cameron which is the Jo
kept changing so much about surfer
ninjas that at the end it was it was
Snyder for me surf ninjas in name only I
cannot endorse surf ninjas just because
everything kept changing about it and
feeling it's a nostalgic movie would you
change everything then that's completely
fair and then the style just not so much
anywhere so we're between clueless I
should not have pain and the last
starfighter for me and Cameron and and
Kent both argued very well I think what
ultimately turned me around was I liked
that Ken kept the core of his movie
intact was able to keep a lot of what
was unique about it but update it but
still give people that like the original
enough and I felt like Cameron was
knocked down enough by others saying
that like yes clueless Anna Simon it was
such a hallmark but there have been
other movies teen movies that have come
out since then that served that role to
serve that function why does it have to
be clueless right when there have been
so many others so my vote goes to Ken
okay the last one for
can Danielle can you help us out let's
find out all right do me a solid you
guys let's see if here's my eye my eye
is late I don't know what's going on
with 53% of the vote the last
starfighter 27% Stephanie Hayes 19%
clueless as far as other things
mentioned again overwhelmingly Honey I
Shrunk the Kids people want to see tiny
kids get tinier a minute to be hugged I
stroked the kids yeah all right so this
is a great moment in sports we are tied
1-1 1 so we are going to the tie break
it works just like the speed round
except with one more person so I will
ask the question shout out your answer
then we'll get 20 seconds from each of
you and the order you answered and then
back around the bend for 10 second
rebuttals just like a speed round but
with three people and then Danielle Dan
and myself will determine sadly who will
not move on mm-hmm here is the tiebreak
question it says prompt here it is
bright burn is basically an alternate
reality Superman horror movie
besides Superman which movie superhero
would be the most scary if they suddenly
turned evil
aside Superman Captain Marvel Captain
Marvel
the Hulk
Captain America okay we have Captain
Marvel the Hulk and Captain America its
Ken Cameron Joe in that order
ken twenty seconds begin when you speak
look I watched avenge team end times and
I'll tell you you know this powerful
character in that movie was Captain
Marvel is so powerful they had to kind
of take her out of the movie because she
shows up and she wants to decide that
fights over fight is over imagine she
starts using those powers for e Val she
don't need no dragon and no fire she's
gonna like think about it and kind of
fly in boom gun you're dead Captain
Marvel it's the choice Cameron
brain and brawn and I bring you a
character that now has both and if he
goes evil we saw him trying to figure
out time travel turned ant-man old young
and all in the middle if you have a man
like that who can also rip your arms off
and he's pure evil he's got that little
devil on his shoulder
I think you're completely screwed as far
as we can tell the only person who could
take the Hulk out was vanos and he's off
the board
I think this fight is about evil power
versus a complete loss of hope Captain
America is people's beating heart and if
that's ripped out like imagine the
fallout from that like death stars
explode dragons can be killed but like
the loss of faith in Steve Rogers
turning evil I think would just shatter
people that's ultimate evil like power
cool strength cool energy blast cool
ten-second rebuttals starting with whom
sorry with you okay if this man should
fall who should pick up the flag
lieutenant Falcon he's got it he's our
new Captain America out with the old in
with the new
that's great hulks great but that's
contained in one area you could stop him
with something like say a person was
superpowers from above
you simply told me people would be
really sad if Captain America turned
evil you didn't tell me on what the
world would be other than sad as far as
Captain Marvel goes if you just puts
Jude Law or some past in front of her
she'll freeze for a minute evil Hulk
he's got nothing to worry about
I think evil would rally to someone as
inspirational as Captain America it
would throw the entire world disarray
with throw things in anarchy and the
shield has to be passed off can you
imagine how tame did that shield is when
the guy that's evil drops and you have
to pick it up there's no recovering from
that all right
there it is Daniel Radford what are you
thinking oh you know these were all
fantastic arguments but I've got to say
on this one there was something I feel
like no one did a good enough job of
knocking down Joe's Captain America and
the idea that he is it isn't just about
how fast or strong he is but the idea
that he would be able to rally people
around him because he's evil and even if
there is another Captain America that
title would now be tainted chilling
upsetting what would Joe
oh and who would not move oh sorry okay
thanks oh yeah no worries I don't like
this so the one that I think is as
compelling as it isn't as interesting as
it is all I heard about Captain Marvel
was boom boom hit hit boom
and then all I heard about Hulk was the
same boom boom hit hit boom so it was
between which two were gonna be the
hideous and I have to agree with with
you that it's Hulk is kind of contained
and in one place we've seen them get
beaten before so sorry Cameron I love
you Dan very similar I love Joe's
argument I thought that was a great
angle so I would advance Joe
automatically and then yes I think the
Canon Cameron both had similar arguments
about power ultimate power and for me I
agree with Danielle when it when that's
the criteria and I think you're gonna go
with the character that has the most
ultimate power as shown in the movies I
thought ken made in that case the best I
would also advance Joe and Ken Joe and
Ken you're moving on to the speed round
Cameron you did a fantastic job thank
you sir fair now I have more audiences
to yell at me and tell me I'm not good
at the
all right Swede round again I'll ask a
question shout out your answers 20
seconds 20 seconds 1002 10 second
rebuttal and that did not count for
points so it still stands to take on
this camera
take a break all right here we go
Chris Rock has been tapped to reimagine
the Saw franchise for Lionsgate what
comedian should be brought in to
reimagine a classic horror franchise we
need the comedian and the franchise oh
that's good good luck you two
[Laughter]
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go Adam Sandler
and Nightmare on Elm Street don't ask me
why sign here
five three Ellen DeGeneres and the
haunting Ellen in the haunting of course
all right so we have Sandler and
Nightmare on Elm Street Ellen DeGeneres
and the haunting throwing stuff against
the ball can 22nd again when you speak
hey Freddy is about being in your
nightmares what's more haunting than
constantly here at happy overall Adam
Sandler's reason get back at everyone
he's been cast aside no one cares about
him anymore right no he's gonna come
back and guess what worse he's gonna
bring all of his friends and they're
gonna haunt your dreams it's keep keep
Hoover do a vegan please please ring the
bell
Joe how I'd like to bring in a jte role
from a different show and ask you to
repeat the question he has two left
[Music]
Chris Rock has been tapped to reimagine
the Saw franchise for Lionsgate what
comedian should be brought in to
reimagine a classic horror franchise
when he answered by five seconds so
because you technically got some extra
time to think there oh sorry
okay that's fair okay so I think the
devil in the details for a good horror
movie is is is the the atmosphere the
small details of the world and Ellen
DeGeneres is very good at painting a
picture that's what her stand-up is all
about the small details the weirdness
that things that stand out and those are
the things that are gonna translate into
creepiness and spookiness and a movie
like the haunting which isn't jump
scares it's atmosphere its details its
storytelling and that's where Ellen
excels ten-second remodels hi I love
Ellen I've been a fan of Ellen for a
long time but yeah I think you're
talking about a horror movie was like a
kitschy dancing and kind of like
laughter and light-hearted I think even
when she tries she's out - the scarier
where Adam Sandler has been scaring a
lot of people for a lot of years I don't
think this is about their content this
is about their style and and so that's
what I think Ellen would bring to this
whereas Adam Sandler has proven no
matter what genre he does he does just
sort of eventually just end up going and
that's kind of what you get all right
you know the thing you just did there
that's the thing I want to like Sandler
as that I don't know what that still
with - what you said I don't know what
the Ellen haunting movie would be so I'd
go with the goofball Freddy Krueger I'm
going with Ken Danielle I have to
disagree if only because I heard Ken's
basic argument is Oh buddy I don't do a
good Adam Sandler but that was the crux
of Kent's argument and while I agree
that that can be scary I felt like Joe
really had an understanding of other
than just you know funny and character
bits what specifically about the way
that Ellen tells a story would would
lend itself to Horace I'm gonna go Joe
okay it's one one damn very close to me
and I I wished I could Shogun a little
bit deeper on because I like the idea of
like Ellen brings a lot of detail but
but but the heart but the horror of it
was missing for me and for it was a more
of a clear-cut thing about Adam
Sandler's back and he's pissed and
everything you've hated for ever is
coming back and he's gonna torture you
with it in your dream that just as a
stronger harder pitch for me so I would
go on to that do all right can you get
the point
Cameron how's that cupcake good stuff
it's good I would have given the
Exorcist to Tim and Eric here's question
ever to the speed round ghostbusters the
videogame make it a remastered release
what classic movie comedy would inspire
the best video game Caddyshack joestar
Blues Brothers okay Caddyshack Blues
Brothers classic late seventies early
eighties comedy uh all right Ken your
first sports games are big business and
who doesn't want to be Rodney
Dangerfield Chevy Chase Bill Murray dad
a card from Caddyshack oh if you want
put them in a video game you get to
select you get to be the players wow
that's a fun tournament guess what I did
I defeated Todd Webb with Rodney
Dangerfield I know that's a bad Rodney
King start doing lines of alert the only
thing crappier than actual golf is video
game golf oh my god but imagine
combining dance games singing games and
car chase games into one crazy PR
experience and that's the Blues Brothers
game that would be insane Guitar Hero
super fun playing the songs with the
band or you could be a singer or you
could be doing dance moves like a dance
dance revelution and then you got to get
in a car you got to drive cruisin USA
style it's combining all sorts of fun
physical active
genres can I think your game would need
to come with a warning that might cause
seizures and every living creature it
senses I think this is danger and guess
what golf games video games sports games
sgt the boat their big business and
people would want this my game would
have cool hidden trophies you can find
they all be orange wimps all sorts of
like really fun Easter eggs from the
games and then you've got all that
classic music that's part of the fun of
like a Guitar Hero's all those cool
collections of songs that you could play
through as the Blues Brothers alright
Dan Morelle as a former guitar hero it
is yest and also for Tiger Woods golf
enthusiast many our Spitz on both well
it's the reality of both of those games
but the one that sounds more fun to me
is the one where you can do anything
everything I don't I don't really know
what a Caddyshack golf game would offer
me you know I lose a shoe every have
four different controllers and dropping
the one you get in the car then you pick
up the guitar and all the other thing
also can I don't know she was spending
the last five seconds of you around
saying ding-ding please
so Joe you get the point we are a tie
ballgame good general knows when he's
defeated and tries to live to fight
another day
here's question number three we are all
tied up at 2:00 to Batman versus the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles is new on
VOD but regardless of how that plays out
what really win in a fight between
Batman and the shredder Batman okay
writer Ken Joe you're first with Batman
aside from being rich Batman's powers
preparation he prepares for everyone he
always has a plan you always has a
back-up plan one time shredder got
beaten by a dumpster and then another
time a mutated shredder got beaten by a
dock like shredders kind of posts where
and sharp things this pen sharp this
doesn't make me intimidating hi I'm the
shredder
Batman is is a killer he's also a
trained ninja he also has sharp things
on his wrists Batman isn't really a
killer because it really really takes a
toll on the motional if you have to
shredder was raised on the streets now
man he's been living in the dumpsters
where Bruce wayne/batman he's up in his
high ivory tower I guess I'll come down
after seven years and save Gotham
shredders I don't let the the costume
for you it's what's in his heart and
he's from the garbage and he's gonna
take it down and throw you out sure is
basically a visual gag where someone in
big armor can barely move and they fall
forward he's gotten tanked by a rat he's
gotten tanked by trucks Batman okay
again hyperbole not a killer but he's a
badass he's unstoppable he's down there
in the streets he's mixed it up at the
best go get a rebuttal yes okay big
showy costume they can move here's
Batman in every movie you can't mom he's
not gonna win a fight against a monster
like shredder come on get out of here
Joestar roko sake would be very proud
you know you're right I will the Michael
Keaton cowl aside I Jose opening
argument the shredder was beaten by like
a dumpster in a dock and all these
different things yeah I do star that was
a knockout blow that was unrecoverable
for me psycho Joe Danielle you know I
have to agree with things Joe just had
all of that John you were gonna beat the
ninja bastard the ninja question
all right Joe you do not fight a
dumpster and Lucy thank you thank you
dan facts on decking can all right
it is game point here for Joe star ken
needs us to keep her going
Kevin Feige now says the Mandarin the
real Mandarin this time will eventually
appear in the MCU who should play him
Ben Kingsley damn it
okay I'm gonna go with I'm gonna go with
Ken Jeong okay dr. ken versus mr. bin
just not a doctor I think this works
whether you like the twist or you don't
like the twist if you don't like the
twist then boom Ben Kingsley steal your
Mandarin if you like the twist then it's
a twist on a twist it's a double twist
he pretended not to be the man to get
away from Tony Stark the most brilliant
way possible boom he is actually the
Mandarin he is actually that weird
intimidating guy that was making those
videos and causing all those threats
he's he's a great fantastic actor I and
it should be dr. ken versus Sir Ben my
bad how yes sir can you ever once watch
choose an answer you don't understand
why I chose but you have to find it here
we go dr. ken I you know have you
watched him in role models he is an
intimidating evil king of a LARPing
group
I picked that character and put them in
the Mandarin costume in heaven fight
Iron Man Iron Man jr. whoever Kevin
Feige he's gonna throw until a marvel
lather rinse repeat movie and have him
fighting a big third act with CGI all
over dr. Candace's chance to shine
I think dr. Kent as the Mandarin is the
nightmare reason why they were trying to
avoid doing the actual fermenter and
whereas I think Ben Kingsley whether you
play him as a new guy or the same guy
lands on gravitas this is a chance for
Marvel to maybe correct some wrongs for
years in the comic book it's a chance to
really give this character his own
identity and maybe he sheds that name
maybe shows that name just becomes dr.
Mandarin I don't know that makes any
difference but it sounds cool to me what
name did he shed I don't
[Laughter]
this was really Ken fighting himself to
not lose the point damn it's been me for
43 years but oddly strangely weirdly
enough I
I wasn't digging Joe's argument allotted
to me it was like it felt like the only
thing worse to me than a fan then maybe
a risky decision is a company chickening
out on that risky decision and trying to
have it both ways and I feel like that's
what it would be with Ben Kingsley like
stick to your guns at least with Ken
Jong you'll have something different and
it won't be just like oh sorry fans
we're gonna what do you want what do you
want us to do okay then we'll do that
I'm going with the risk I'm going with
the risky pick and I'm going with Kim
Jong all right Danielle it's all I need
I yeah this one this one was really
tough for me because it's also you have
to give it up for someone who was
fighting and battling an uphill battle
but again this is one of those ones
where unfortunately at the end Joe just
had we was coming with some facts I
didn't get as many facts from Ken you
were trying really hard though it I have
to give it up if I can give half a point
I would but I got to give it to Joe yeah
this is a you know Ken pitched something
fun but it didn't I don't know is a
little bit of a square peg round hole
where as I thought Joe finessed it just
enough to at least Jedi mind trick me
into going with it this round and Joe
star you just one movie fun right
[Applause]
Joe well-played good shake and congrats
on epic ninja knowledge please go ahead
and yes they would have the congrats are
all to these two gentlemen at the table
at this table Ken I'm so proud of you in
this book it's incredible I've been I've
been thumbing through it a little bit
it's it's so good every every line of
this just makes me smile and you come
through it through and through Cameron
the elder I know I'm pitching your guys
stuff for you and now you have nothing
to say but I always have something dude
you deserve to be where you where you're
at thank you buddy
but you you work your ass off you're so
talented congratulations yeah Congrats
all of these guys thank you Joe lovely
lovely Cameron please tell us where you
can find us out some stuff out yeah so
tonight if you're watching this live at
on El Rey Network is a relation you go
check that out so there's third episode
also on Twitter and now it's at the
Cameron rice change that up because
professional job stuff but also check
out again my photo account cameras photo
some cool stuff up there I've been doing
big hair stuff and I got stuff with Emma
that we just did variaty style kind of
so go check those out awesome Thank You
Cameron well fought today can you pushed
it to the limit just like one more time
in Sport Chalet and yeah great having
here fun stuff good to be a especially
thanks to Joe star one of the sincerest
nicest people in the business and
emmy-nominated honest trailer rider by
the way and what our nicest people have
my camera up doing so great though I
have pitched constantly to cam to take
photos of me cosplaying as 80s comedian
Bruce baby balm and an adult diaper but
he won't do it I'll do it I'm sure life
okay
I put a lot of work into this and you
guys know I love Star Wars why we love
Star Wars available go to Ken apps are
calm also by the way hey I'll be in
Houston tomorrow night doing comedy you
go to Mark Ellis live.com for tickets
and the lavash Motown Saturday at the
Booker T Arena in Custer yeah
star wars mines I know it since we've
gotten to the biz anytime we've talked
Star Wars so many times on screen
junkies so congrats on that bank and
yeah I echo all of that thank you sir
dan Merle good stuff any box office
predictions for this weekend it's gonna
be interesting to see how John wick does
versus the Avengers there's a lot of if
I were if I were a betting man I would
say I think he's got a really good shot
at dethroning the Avengers especially
with the the good reviews and the buzz
the movies getting but we'll see what
happens maybe he'll beat the Avengers by
a nose cuz he's on a horse come on ah
Daniel Radford hello um yeah you can
just you know you can find me at Daniel
Radford on Twitter Daniel underscore on
Instagram I have a wrestling podcast
called tights and fights where I talk
about wrestling edition continue to
watch the honest trailers because that's
how I get new dresses okay bye hell yeah
Thank You Danielle a couple of big
announcements about things coming up
this weekend on screen junkies a little
show called Game of Thrones is ending
this weekend and watching Thrones will
be live after the finale so tune in for
a live watching Thrones and you can you
know scream at them about how many often
Weis ruined your childhood or whatever
and enjoy the hell out of that also so
that's on Sunday night then on Saturday
before that power levels drops a brand
new show from screen junkies it's
animated it's fun it's answering and
exploring a lot of nerd topics and
that's gonna be fun so look for that on
Saturday and watching Thrones live on
Sunday and I'm Hal Rudnick this has been
super fun times with everybody in this
room
shout out Billy big shout out JT shadow
owl nation hoot hoot hit me up on
Twitter at Hal Rudnick bye-bye everybody
you